well i try to work on new impressions
you know what i mean like like fresh
torn from the headlines of the
newspapers of the journals of the you
know
well
using today's headline you just do a
little bit i got a lady joel i'm working
on a new one
yeah
i do live
okay um
um
i'm lady dole running for president lady
dole wants to be president i don't want
to work at the blood bank anymore i want
to be president of the united states
lenny dawg
[Applause]
you know how oh like when people are
married for a long time they start to
sound like each other
i think that's what happened with bob
and little girl
you are really wild i mean you're wild
in that show and you're a wild person
what
[Applause]
the one i remember was
wait wait i don't want to do view jokes
because if you if you you start a battle
with the joy bear you're not going to
win
no you'll win easily
you've admitted that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life i've
read six six what kind of a woman would
be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
you know old joy bay area i don't think
she wants you to tell everybody it's in
her wikipedia oh she's i think a lot
older than 70. yeah that's he looks
great that sounds about right to me 70.
no i never i didn't think of her jesus
christ almighty when did she break 50. i
like her i like her too she reminds me
she reminds me of like your old aunt or
something yeah with their funny opinions
you know what i mean the view is about
you
[ __ ] what kind of henna house horse
[ __ ] is that i went to that friar's club
once i never seen a roast or anything
like that joy but i see i went one time
i loved playing poker i had a bit of a
gambling problem for a while and i
couldn't get enough poker games right so
this dude he told me you gotta go to the
friars club man there's a big poker game
there right i have to talk to four
people
so so i go to the friars club barbara
are you listening
[Applause]
they told me this is great there's this
big poker game right so i go there and
there's all these old dudes there right
and they're all comics from like 50
years ago and i don't know who the hell
they are you know and it's not like
famous comics like milton berle or
anybody like that it's these b level
comics from 50 years ago you know like a
freddie roman and dudes like that right
so they're all playing poker you know
they're all playing poker and i'm
playing poker i just want to play poker
but they're all like making jokes you
know and every joke they're making
involves me being a gay dude
you know what i mean like they'll go ah
here you go kid here's a you know be
like a queen i'd get a queen
there's a lady for the lady
[Applause]
and they'd all laugh you know and i
didn't notice at first i'm just playing
cards and all of a sudden i realized
every joke is me being a homosexual man
right so i'm not a homosexual man as you
well know
[Applause]
i would have sex with you while you were
awake
[Applause]
all right and then i'm playing and all
of a sudden this old dude next to me
goes ah kid just uh uh you gotta you
gotta show them uh show them what you're
made of you insult them too you know so
i'm like oh so there's an old dude
there's like 70 years old so i go hey uh
they're old dude you probably i've had a
few guys who had sex with a few guys
right he goes
see i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a
a fresh start because we don't want any
more murderers i think we should just go
on to the next question how about the
murderer yeah oh clinton he murdered a
guy yeah you know
you're not awesome but i have no
accusations with that that's a little
too that's the way it does let's just
let's just go on to the next book
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either and i'm being
very nice okay
i'll be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
we don't need no one to get into this
and i don't want to hear it and this is
not the place to make those accusations
and you're supposed to be funny
there you go
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara we're now going to
you will not be invited back if you
don't shut up
[Applause]
hello
oh yeah oh no uh the thing is this
there uh you know matt strauss yeah the
producer the producer he told me it
would be funny he said like why don't
you carry a cell phone on and then let
it ring and then pretend like there's a
guy on it is there anybody on it no it's
a thing pretending you know what norm
you're a dead man
planning to announce her retirement
what's next for babs
death
the old nor macdonald is back they can't
memorize things like because in each
script we get each week there may be
there's like six seven hundred words wow
and you have to say them in order you
know what i mean
that ain't easy what is it like on the
set of that show with you
what is it like well what do you mean
what do i mean well because you're
celebrating
well i'm just saying it's hard to
memorize we're not walking around the
set going hey uh
[Applause]
you have actually annoyed one of your
idols who is that oh the great bill
cosby yeah what'd you do oh my god i
love that guy he's my hero you know just
like you maybe joy or uh bill clinton
would be your hero i i love
i love
there's no stopping you isn't it no you
seem to like bill clinton and this man
leads into our show on friday night
i know it's all right his career is over
after this anyway who cares
go ahead norm
no bill clinton who's a great man
obviously you know everybody has their
opinions right
are you moving along
oh guys
god
carter's been yeah
coffee what are you drinking in there no
bill cosby is a great man first time
there has never been any accusations
toward bill cosby about anyone will you
just tell us what you did bill cosby oh
i i met him i i opened for him at a club
and he was a great man you know he's my
hero of all time you know how funny bill
cosby yeah so get to the point
i'm going past menopause
so i went to see star wars i have never
seen any of the star wars and i felt
terrible about it until i learned that i
never saw it i never saw the first one i
never saw any of them no you never saw
anything you never wanted to say star
wars no i never seen it i never liked
them
i don't like those science fiction
because my dad always hated him and you
know how you you try to be what your dad
you try to be you know what i mean
and i remember when i was a kid i
watched that twilight zone remember that
show yeah and oh my god my dad hated it
because it was too fantastical and he
thought i should be doing the chores and
i remember one time me and my brother
were watching star wars